- La dépouille de la reine
poursuit sa route.
C'est suivi de ses quatre
enfants, dont un désormais roi,
que le cortège funèbre a quitté.
Sous le regard souvent
silencieux du public massé
le long du Royal Mile, le mile
des enfants, orphelin.
C'est à ça que pensait Leanne,
son fils endormi dans ses bras,
voyant le roi Charles arriver
aux portes de la cathédrale.
Ce sa mère après tout qu'il doit
enterrer dit-elle.
Élisabeth II était chez elle
en Écosse. Nombreux sont ceux
dans la foule qui peuvent
ne rencontne rencontne rencontn,
fortuite, personnelle avec
la reine, mais peutant
de que la comtesse de Mansfield.
"J'ai beaucoup de chance dit-
elle, je viens d'un endroit où
on couronne les rois d'Écosse et
palais."
Elle se rappelle d'une femme
drôle, intelligen'un'un'un'un'un
amour partagé pour les animaux.,
tenait à vivre l'histoire
avec un grand H.
ELIZA SWANSON
- Je crois que les gens oublient
qu'elle était notre enfant
erre et l'Écosse,
mais aussi pour le Canada.
Je crois que c'était le moment
important dans l'histoire
canadienne aussi.
- L'étudiante à l'université
e croit qu'il est peu
probable que la monarchie
n'a plus aujourd'hme
importance pour le Canada.
fabriquer autant d'une connexion
avec Charles.
(chant choral)
À l'i
dite de réflexion, où les chants
ont bercé la douleur.
Cette première cérémonie en
présenceil de la reine
est maintenant terminée.
La famille royale a quitté
la cathédrale de Saint John'ce c
de venir se recueillir sur
eil de la reine.aimsworth aimswi
Michael ont conduit des heures
depuis l'Angleterr
Elle a obtenu le tout premier
des bracelets qui permet aux
gens de s'approcher du cercueil.
"Je pense que nousoreoreoreoreoe
du mal à se résoudre à sa
disparitt
que mardi elle accomplissait
encore son devoir.
Et jeudi, elle n'était plus là.r
lorsqu'on voit le cercueil."
Son mari a souvent croisé
la reine pendant sa carrièredan.
Une dernière cér
un devoir auquel il ne voulait
surtout pas se soucrire.
Ici Marie-Ève Bédard,
Radio-Canada, É